[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
damn why Sheree Ted shot with a gun oh
don't give me daddy's labor out here in
an alley now and stop giving me argument
give me max early max I got your well oh
yeah what you been drinking
Joel Wells has been a concrete block
holding up a brick summer for the past
five years
why is dying [ __ ] we just don't like
make accommodate there all right mother
look I'll make sure it hits Joe well for
my fee he's about ready for the old cat
song I think he's having optical
delusions 20 dollars and 72 cents and
standing on my feet all day
oh yeah just mercenary
[Music]
[Music]
mm-hmm McLean you're now scanning it the
masterpiece of a master you are now
perusing the produce of pure genius
in fact you are now gazing upon the
nucleus of an Iraq fight immoral oh no
this is all very nice clutch but I'm
tired I'd like to go home what a lack of
depreciation mr. Miggs you'll give me
your attention for just a moment I'll
never know explain the intricacies of
this chair this is all very nice clutch
but I'm tired
so you're tired so what so you're at
night me only trying to fix it other
customers to get the proper enumeration
for their money
now get a gander at this give myself a
hot foot good night
I gotta fix that no no no no no please
clutch not now come on come on
gosh
[Music]
double-crosser
[Music]
I don't know what I'm going to do my
life hasn't been the same since my
brother-in-law had to die and leave me
this place she left it to me yeah but
you weren't retired you hadn't worked
hard all your life like me I'm an old
man what do you think I am
kindergarten stock he's gone somebody's
gone disappeared is bear moose listen
max I ain't blind and I know Joe will
when I see him hmm
my fees really at it tonight I think
something bit him maybe we better go see
and I can get watch him oh sure I'm sure
hey what is it what my tower wait for
you
just too bad might be I'd advise you to
see an optimist very funny
you're gone eggs on lock up after you I
wouldn't trust the MiGs
on his condition I don't mind waiting is
there anything I can do all right gotta
wait around here lieutenant hurry shows
nothing we'd be out of here in a couple
of minutes it's broken down rubber he'll
let up they detach him off the floor why
don't you shut up
well I hope you'll all be out of here
soon I'm very tired what do you think I
am I'll bite
what are you well if it ain't Joe
typewriter itself Oh miss Gallagher
there's been some kind of a trouble they
gotta go give me a match will you a
twerp like you smoking that big thing
sometimes come in little packages you'll
keep on there make your [ __ ]
junior grade think you can afford this
what's the trouble I really don't know
how did you do today any better any
better imagine just because I lost my
expense account in a crap game they put
me on a leg job in some corny police
station out in the sticks
ooh my paper for crying out loud aren't
you listening oh this is miss Gallagher
mr. Murphy she lives upstairs over the
exhibit a fleabag renovated into an
apartment they got a match just when you
give me this damage beat it I think it's
a nice little place you've got upstairs
no places go don't mind me tonight mr.
Miggs I'm just mad at the world
she's a reporter but you would know it
you're a disgrace to the Chronicle they
said and we are gonna beat you a lesson
they said get that way you're not gonna
teach me a lesson
me the one who covered the gardener
Stanley hanging and how about the
Kingman fire I even had the news boys
crying I wasn't crying
you you need a news bulletin Pete Willis
any data as a reporter for you Pete
Willis that double-crossing snake
double-crossing snake got my father and
a clear after being sent up for that
might a rat didn't he he finally got it
really done and pinned it on him didn't
he that took brains and fight him more
you watch me call him a snake about a
month ago while you two was lollygagging
around again
should have seen him wife it was really
a panic I wish you'd quit rattling your
head i got all i can do worrying about
what happens with joe well joe well what
about him
I find him murdered then he disappears
again yeah I give my eyeteeth for an
exclusive on it if it really happened
but only walked Joe well maybe then I
could make that reg I work on taking out
the doghouse and you a doghouse looks
good Oh quiet is he very important this
Joe welds never heard of Joe Wells no it
is total ignorance for you do you not
never read no newspapers Joe world's was
just the biggest noise in the rackets
that's all why Joe had so many notches
on his Tommy can it look like a first
saw and fight a war up then you
disappeared about five years ago and
everybody thought his own boys done it I
still think so well I'm still thinking
about that reward five grand for the guy
that find him and I had him sure sure
you did nothing but stop making it worse
for yourself thinking about that five
grand how you gonna stop thinking about
five grand
well I'm going to bed good night happy
nightmare hey might be just between you
and me we've got really Joe Wells your
head look good I'm the guy that put the
pinch on on that time at the World's
Fair a day
well I'd know I'm would nice
[Music]
so well
[Music]
too hot in here I'm gonna wait outside
the lieutenant yeah I guess I could use
some fresh air too
[Music]
[Music]
you a number please please yeah and WI
elevator yeah I'm a heavy number but I
must have displaced it I wanted to be
complimentary no together huh yeah wait
but make it snappy will ya
Oh Pete this is clutch but much clutch
you know Oh clutch what do you know
let's do it the wrench works come on
come on yeah yeah yeah you tell the kid
to go to a picture show and call back
later
I gotta get home and I'm out two bucks
already yeah come on well yeah go ahead
clutch nobody's listening look it's a
cop over here but NEMA Murphy claims you
found the body of Jill Wells uh-huh
I don't know out in an alley someplace
hey you say might be from him here's my
cabbage well just shoot again yeah
what's he use he always wins anyway I'm
Gallagher knows huh okay sweetheart I'll
be over in five minutes
hey where you going what about our dough
you don't have to leave polishing you
spend the rest of the evening in this
joint Turner what are you gonna do for
money you've won it all and don't break
the glass right what did I already live
here oh this will be much safer in the
car well how do you
quarter
[Music]
[Music]
oh what a lucky stiff stop telling me
that Murphy so you think your hedge oh
well so he I think he got away so what
what so I think I'm telling you that dog
[Music]
well I think you're Daffy our non-gaap
gonna come down here listen to you
gentlemen I won just a minute you but
please remember who is this guy let's
mix he owns the joint he wants to close
up oh well we'd be out here in a couple
of minutes
well I hope so I'm so tired
start right at the beginning
[Music]
Chronicle extension 13
hello gotcha Marty Gallagher look get
over to my place quickly William and
bring that camera pal
yeah yeah time now get over here before
it boils over
[Music]
give you a buzz I didn't know if
anything was up worth investigating
clutch hey Pete you got a match I
thought I thought about picking her
things up out of the street out of the
street la Pieta Fillmore what do you
mean out of the street hello mr. Willis
haven't seen you around lately yeah
that's right what happened with you and
Gallagher did the Milka romance
slightly curdled well shall we say
temporarily sour and oh boy she thinks I
shoot craps with loaded dice as you got
anything to do with that Washington
assignment you went home in on last week
where she lost her expense account her
expense account where's she now upstairs
let's go in here and see what's going on
right I don't know think Murphy I don't
believe hey what is this who called you
in Willis I have little birdies working
for me max little birdies with golden
wings oh yeah
someday I'm gonna clip them golden wings
for you good hmm I don't believe a word
of your whole story where you start
clipping how about giving me a match
Joel Wells is dead on a mackerel he's
Bennett and he's been that way for a
long time boy you never can tell you say
you're sorry Murph ah so what are you
suggesting that we conduct our
house-to-house canvass in search of the
body and on this kind of evidence I
don't care what you do from now on you
not let this thing obsess yeah you might
tell me more about it mark what did you
I grabbed the shot
what shot hey what is this what are you
trying to pull Willis I don't know he's
not my boy well Gallagher called me
that's all I know she was all excited
about something she hadn't wanted me to
take some pictures Gallagher who the
blazes is Gallagher AG some Galan lives
upstairs that time to do it the
newspapers well go on home we ain't got
nothing to photograph the day Matt plays
enough on it I don't know maybe either
that perhaps he's gone to bed yeah he's
[ __ ] for the evening she called our
staff a few minutes ago and told me to
tell you that it was all a mistake a
mistake yeah oh that ain't like
Gallagher she don't play hunches Paul
believe me pal she be highly insulted
that you ever spoil her sleep Thanks
she'd be inflamed yeah that's the laugh
spoil her sleep oh sorry oh why goodbye
goodbye
what are you figuring feet feel it let
me go with you maybe I can help you I
said later all right I'll be around
yeah package on it's like I'm back
alright thanks Pete
mucho crotches
[Music]
that's your mari charlie don't you know
my knock anymore you stick your nose in
their feet well let's not throw my
typewriter at your head baby can't you
talk without screaming this is business
it's all away mister well as I'm very
busy you're busy you don't think looking
for Joe Wells is any fun yeah you're not
still sore about that crap game are you
honey
that's one thing I'm not talking about
that's four kitchenette you know they
weren't my dice they belong to Charlie
Baker that's the closet yeah
besides they weren't crooked I just ran
into a streak of luck that's all
isn't that what you call it uh-huh good
if you're looking for a dirt it's not
there and Joe Wells either I didn't
think you were that dumb honey if you
never know aah Oh Peter I'm really not
mad anymore
I mean about the craps game I'm busy no
kidding I think I've looked the first
acts that play I told you about I was
just playing around with the idea when
you're not did I tell you you were
gorgeous tonight honey I'm such a liar
writing a play huh while detective
lieutenant Hurley's plainclothesmen
stalked through New York streets
searching apartments and alleyways
creating terror in the hearts of
innocent bystanders the body of Joe
world was lying in line we're so good
why don't you finish it you know this is
really horrible you should go back to
writing love Lancome yeah well it's a
lot more exciting than that stuff they
print under your name all right baby I
want to help you where do you got it
that what that is just in case it's fast
oh sure
if you don't get out of here I'll call
the cops ha ha ha yes you will
what are you gonna do nothing I'm gonna
let you finish the play but I'm afraid
you're gonna write the last act in jail
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
okay okay I'll look into it right away
Murphy I can't give this thing anymore
my turn
will you quit shoving my Kara why don't
you get out of here why should I inform
you that this happens to be my place of
employment
ah I'll send over a couple of boys and
you could scout around maybe I'll find
something maybe a wall oh I just got a
hearty call to look into a shooting a
couple of bucks away you want to go
no thanks I'm going home you know early
to bed early to rise well anyway you
want
uh-huh now you wait around outside the
prowl car pick up any new developments I
don't know yeah well thanks for calling
clutch I'll see you around right but I'm
tonight tonight mr. Willis they carry it
upbeat I'll go put on the night light in
the back you'll be ready now
[Music]
whoo
[Music]
[Music]
take care of that Gwendolyn
don't let the smoking in your eyes
[Music]
what makes what's the matter what are
you so dissipated about you look like it
fell in a barrel of flour out there out
there sitting out there who's sitting
out there there's a corpse out there
playing cards life
[Music]
he's really there what do you think
you're doing you shouldn't have done
that clutch I'm just telephoning the
police
do you want to get us in trouble we got
something on a miss that's tip is really
rigor mortis but I got a telephone a
British what are you doing you is in
last year's brains no to happen if you
call in the cops they'll throw bright
lights in your eyes they'll give you two
rubber hose treatment tough break get
down bring me down for what what not as
a clever injection or killing that guy
out there that's for what I didn't kill
him he got in here by mistake you try to
tell a cop stat you seen what happened
to my own man didn't you don't think you
had a motive you'll be a felony what we
got to do is get rid of that body about
it you mean hide out in the street
behind some nice cans
yeah but you mean to have it bounce back
on you know morning uh no got to get it
out of the neighborhood way out oh my
goodness our today but but but how well
we'll take the course and put it in your
car and deposit it someplace far away in
this vicinity come on let's get your car
all my hair get my cigar
[Music]
[Music]
for you I think you and I have a little
business to transact business if my
price isn't right of what make me
different
that's the body of Joe well lucky I
slept up yesterday isn't 11 who fails to
impress me miss Gallagher no Gallagher
[Music]
will you stop scaring me with that gun
if this is a gag and Pete Wallace sent
you
let's not get away from a septic miss
Gallagher if you haven't got the body of
Joe Wells in this apartment I've
convinced that you know where it is
you see I followed the blood spots from
the Empress Hotel across the elevator
your staircase and now this I know he
was shot and I know he couldn't bag
himself much further where is he
all right what's the use the bodies
downstairs the exhibits now we're
getting somewhere
I don't imagine you want to meet the
cops who are down it now mr. Gallagher
let's be honest with each other
we both heard the police car drive away
a few minutes ago that's too bad I'll
follow you
[Music]
miss Gallagher
thank you miss Gallagher yes ought to
make you stay
he owns ugly I guess he's closing up
you'll get back in a week
[Music]
I got upstairs again let's perambulate
that we raised a minute please clutch
that's all I need miss Gallagher
catching door wish just happened to
remember the tap on your courage down we
got to put it up do we have to do that
now mr. makes you wouldn't want to risk
your social standing by being seen shelf
runner demolish gangsta to the streets
would you know I never mind
you should there rest I'll put the top
up
[Music]
I don't know I don't get it what's your
angle where you heading what's in the
world you want with that corpse let's
say it's a collector's item well as long
as we have to wait I'd like to get the
story on paper be wasting your time you
won't have the body to prove it after
you're through with it it'll turn up
somewhere that is a moot question
[Music]
answer it but be careful what you say
[Music]
hello Oh McAndrew
listen lamebrain what do you mean
getting marty out on a wild brains out
for nothing huh tonight at it there is
upset alright so I called Marty so it
was a mistake what about it
why said it was a mistake what do you
want me to do cut my throat well that's
not a bad idea or better still go back
to school learn how to write and don't
you tell me anything about writing
stories I'll be getting by lines when
you've ended up on a copy Debra great
know you're disappointed him something
[Music]
hello bottle popping I guess what are
you doing here well you know I can make
a mistake where'd you get this
oh hi in there well what happened I'm
just the manager of the place heard a
shot about an hour ago and call the
station I couldn't help but if you guys
didn't get here in time
whiteouts whoa and I come in to see the
door was open and I guess they had now
nobody around that's fine what about the
kind of rent of the jury I don't know
not the bottom
Justin living here in the place a week
never showed his face it was just a mug
yeah like what boom little rat-faced guy
with a pinhead like a carp that was Joe
Wells you can tell my shut up I make the
discoveries around here I guess I know
Joe Wells when I hear him now what do
you know about it anyway Hawkshaw where
did you get the key to this room back it
makes it that's what your wealth is now
the girls got it what girl Gallagher
Gallagher yeah you know the reporter
that lives upstairs everybody knows
everything around here with me I'm just
a detective come on let's get back to
Miggs
[Music]
everything's all set that's greteman hit
the gravel I hope we doing right clutch
March we're doing right I figured this
holding up but a process on metal
reduction oh well yeah you got a guide
clutch I'm too nervous
okay but make it feel any better
[Music]
your friends are leaving miss Gallagher
now I relieve you of that body
wait
[Music]
open up its the police their visitors
with me la it's too bad
I'm going to change your plan I don't
think so miss Gallagher not only yours
[Music]
- I can do with this lock
know that key won't work let's try
around front
[Music]
go right through the back door there I'm
gonna for my paper I'll be right up
all right make it snappy
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
grab a hand you and I can make a fortune
here all right Mac put it away no matter
what you're looking for it's not here
you're not the police no I wouldn't call
follow them if I were you
well I should maybe you and I can do
some business why are you selling a lot
of things for instance Joelle's either
the girl was lying or you've
double-crossed her call it anything you
want but I've got the buddy well I can't
talk now
you better get out of here the cops will
be here any minute how about my
apartment
wait an hour I have little choice 1140
Regent place 11:40 region placed and I
hope you're not wasting my time if the
names Willis mr. with it
[Music]
yeah all right Martin yeah I'll take
care of it I'll keep you posted
bye-bye well what'd you find nothing
she's tagging around her apartment with
a lump on her head the size of an egg
trying to find some IQ to put on it she
said some gonna guy clocked her on the
noggin maybe I'm crazy I never been on a
case like this before I'm trying to find
out corpse that somebody stole somebody
stole it
we're up you been the Dame says she
stole a cart
then some guy stole her from her not me
to figure that out all the places would
want a corpse in the first place
[Music]
and alright sweetheart now we're in it
now look you don't think you're gonna
get away with this for long do you you
almost got yourself killed and now the
cops are on your trail let me take over
you're talking to Papa I told her Lee
who took it will you stop bothering me
I've had enough for one night
it's did your party angel somebody's got
the corpse and it's not the guy who
caught you well the way you talk it
sounds like you know more about this
thing than I do I do
I saw the creep just before he got away
the way you're handling things you're
gonna line up in the markets out at your
well please don't be so cute
are you figurin on this I told him I had
the body I want to help you out oh sure
sure you mean you'd like to wheel it out
of me with that sweet talk and hug the
story for yourself baby you know that
they're not story in this for both of it
I told you I haven't got it
stop kidding papa we have to produce a
corpse in an hour so come on I told you
I didn't have it there you go leaving me
holding the bag
all right lady get your coat on you're
going to jail
Oh Oh stealing corpses stuff on your
lady you started this game of puddin
take what about hear me said he saw the
guy that stalked me
I think my never imagination banks I've
told you everything I'm merely an
innocent bystander yeah what are you
trying to do drag him down to your level
yeah
come on I'll pawn your relative honey
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
clutch teeth boy am I glad I found you
home alone yeah yeah we're at me who the
cops well that's too bad but look clutch
I'm expecting your very important
business but this is more important we
took the funny Hill was inspecting a
freight car and I can't chase it
what yeah we found a budding exhibit we
figured we better do something with it
why didn't you call me
it wasn't no time and besides didn't
want Gallagher bust me so I figured I'd
take the putty and hide it and then tell
you and you'd get an exclusive with no
interference alright alright then what
happened we got the body hitting a
freight car right when he got closer
surprises just as we're lamin so we got
scared so your rare so we're under oh
that's just dandy wasn't so dandy from
IG's she got caught what about the
corpse I don't guess they know nothing
about that yet we're all mix you got a
bunch of fishing at chess isn't
prohibited or something have you any
idea where you put it
who makes no their car what site me well
why don't we stand here beating our gums
for let's go get it right Gallagher
watch how if it's that kidney but
earlier can you tell him for me not
renting your motor somebody just put up
your bail bail oh that ain't my
department
better ask out front I know I said
miracles never happen yeah you better
give you right away Harley something
just broke on the well story that's
right a guy named makes complete
confession snatching bodies I didn't
confess anything I just said you said
you stuck the corpse of Joe Wells in a
freight car didn't you what did you do
Oh miss Gallagher I'm just so glad to
see you oh don't tell me they think
you're the cup holders Hara but just
like a nightmare I had no idea I was
going to get in trouble like this that's
what they all say
this ought to be good for murder what
are you trying to do crucify him
what did you put it in a box Conda
freight yards Ohio and Western car I
think you near a water tower at the end
of the yard
we'll get you out of this in no time
mister make none of your funny business
now you keep whittling print yard see
who's going near the freight yard
I just want enough time to get to my
paper take it easy with my story on page
one in the morning you'll be exonerated
in full I hope so
I'm so tired
[Music]
you're waiting for somebody I get the
shoe lady take me to the pranic okay and
step off right
holy counter which they make that 11:40
region place
forget the Chronicle
then you're the guy that bailed me out
and put this just in case mr. Willis
pulls a double-cross you know safety
might convince him in better not mr.
witness says he has a body we're going
over to get it
listen seek will ascertain got anything
but gold whatever he told you I know he
hasn't got it
even mr. Witte has come up with the most
amazing stories why should I believe you
look you've got to believe me he's never
even seen the body of wealth meg stole
it while you and I were playing for
people see upstairs in my apartment and
stop shaking your head I know that
sounds fantastic but the cops caught
makes 20 minutes ago in the freight yard
where he hid the body in a boxcar and
that's where it is now you're sure they
didn't know a corpse was mixed up in it
till he sweated it out of him at the
station
well the police now how do I know going
after the body I guess you're sure
you're not stringing me along let's get
it done
stop handing me that cos I for you do I
look crazy enough to stick my neck out
them you've got the advantage change
that last the best of the freight yards
and hurry
it's down that way by the end of the
yard
did I think yeah yeah Ohio won't listen
good thing you learn to read you know
where you live
[Music]
nice and comfortable Mike come on
give me a hand you get a speak what are
we gonna do it get him out of here
before anybody else finds and then we
can worry what do it like hope you got
the door
[Music]
all right jumped on it a whole let's get
off me oh hi om uestion that's what
makes it
I don't see it it's probably back there
dog this is another of your tricks miss
Gallagher look all I want to do is turn
this thing over to you up here I'm
positive this is a car all that co-op
certainly gets around some crazy thing
that's what I call it why don't you call
the cops when you found it well I
thought what a big big taxes were to
have a police force
I know office here I'm completely
defamed alone and this is where we left
together we left it right in here right
right in there not far from the door
what I ain't here now if you keep it
cool eh
oh my goodness somebody much the stolen
it ah bad again who do you think you're
trying to kid that's the same story the
same game I'm kidding you to choose off
your IDs yeah what are you standing
around for
start look up Sherman sir we just didn't
know you didn't know who knows anything
anymore not there inside maybe it got
moved out of a trash
[Music]
[Music]
perfect mister can I go home now yeah
beat it you no help to me thank you
now I'm awful tired lay two of you
[Music]
but I managed a mr. McAndrews The
Chronicle got to help me but I sold it
for the Chronicle
holy cow can't you understand that shut
up I know you're in a jam so does the
Chronicle for letting you represent it
say who do you think you are stealing a
body off the street and then losing it I
know that a DA's office and the police
department do max earlier on my neck we
don't want any part of it but you've got
to keep me from the law until I find it
again and I've got an idea Pete Willis
that's what I get for hiring a
half-baked woman reporter a screwball
Daffy buttinski your fire you all can't
fire me I quit there doesn't a newspaper
story at the career and your belly
aching because some cops been
complaining well you're gonna soak your
head you ungrateful egg go soak your
head
[Music]
okay you oversized quiz kit what did you
do with it hi angel how did you find us
I guess you wouldn't that creep
following me or giving me gray hairs
well why'd you go out of the clintons
you liked it there they tell me with a
new paint job Sarah care if you'd kept
your big nose out of my business instead
of bringing the cops back to my
apartment I'd never have landed in jail
oh that's a fine way to talk to someone
who's been trying to save a story for
you for me yes
Wow you fix me up so with the police I
don't know what Jen is up oh babe stop
trying to talk me into something there
you go
always be Lippman relax will ya sure
relax along with everything else
McAndrews job scared me well you've been
asking for that for a long time
I know but into the soul good to tell
that stupid old word I head in but
that's not what I'm worried about now
fall look Pete for cryin out loud what
you do with the body the body all I want
to do is give it back to the cops we get
out of this mess I don't want the story
anymore I just want to live stop beating
your brains out what we've got to get
you a better job than the one you've
lost what good will it do me with a lily
in my hand oh yeah what's that read it
Thanks no one of a day or Urich weight
kind of government stamp on it I took it
out a welder's pocket South America
uh-huh
so that's where he's been all these
years under an assumed name Peter
Burnett well the word of the creep fit
in on this I don't know I don't read
Spanish that's why we're waiting for the
gentleman and he's coming here any
minute Pete he's dangerous
ya know how about a drink in the
meantime make mine bourbon good I start
me anymore Ivan just don't pull any fast
ones on me darling that's all hey Leon
try this one for size huh just to keep
you honest trusting soul aren't you we
go together don't we huh I mean even
without gels with some appearance of
yours I still know you're a Hobgoblin
underneath Oh would you still love me
don't you baby
mm-hmm there he is now watch yourself
[Music]
well a man we've been waiting for you
and I'm usually more punctual but I was
delayed
and I can't say I'm too surprised at
seeing you here miss Gallagher oh sit
down make yourself at home mr. say yeah
I can't be calling my guests hey you all
the time my name is Jackie I must say
that I admire the parts of the gastly of
your American press once they smell a
story they stop at nothing till they get
it while we can dispense with the
compliments we want facts you're not
gonna get the body into the answer a few
questions and that depends was with us
that depends entirely upon the questions
well how's this for honor
at the interesting
I see what you and I are beginning to
understand each other you don't want a
story at all you want the diamonds how'd
you guess it junkie catches on quick
doesn't honey like a bird dog now that's
not waste any time shall we
holy cow
those stones represent a quarter of a
million dollars
part of them go to both our Beulah when
I get the buddy well that's just dandy
but as long as we're gonna be partners
you'll have to tell us more yeah you
know just in case of trouble for our
stories giant oh I don't mind I
represent a group of diamond merchants
from whom these turns were stolen and
South America robbery was very cleverly
done by 1 Peter Burnett otherwise Wells
Joe Wells Uruguayan government of the
reward was captured he escaped and you
trailed him here besides him back I was
here before mr. wells arrived but why do
you want the cops when you already have
the diamond well let's go into that
she'll be after you have carried out
your end of the bargain now mr. Willis
where's the body
well that's easy the corpse is riding
around Central Park and a taxi waiting
to be picked up shall we join them
[Music]
we'll be there in a few minutes but the
buddy in the cab mr. witnesses that
quite safe until mahaki he was a friend
of mine to a drunkard take home an hour
spin around the park and I'd pick him up
with a condition that was clever well
who know it jumped from a stiff
I had him propped up in the corner just
as nice as you please if he doesn't
start sliding
I think I'm nuts I had him pinned to the
cushion me
all right drivers go to the park
[Music]
I got a little doggie didn't
[Music]
the driver oh it's you I thought you'd
never get here
everything okay sure he hasn't even
blinked an eye
hey what's this guy been drinking
embalming fluid hey we'll be for long
now let's get it on settle this thing
you two well don't you think it'll be a
little crowded for all four of us real
marriage
in sum what about sergeant I want to get
this thing all the way understand that
what are you worrying about only ones oh
well you want to sit next to him think
you never mind drive it to the Fetty
just a letter
don't you trust me mr. Willis that's
where I relieve you of the body and pay
off
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I thought we were leaving you after we
got on the boat the short trip across
the water can hardly matter now miss
Gilligan especially as we shall be seen
each other anymore after tonight well
we're almost across how about the split
let's stretch our legs and finish our
business at the same time
I can't your wealth walking around with
all that men in it and I thought he was
dead when I left his room at the Empress
Hotel I went down to get a cab to carry
away the body but when I got back he was
gone he must have had just enough life
left dragon for my family
junkie why do you want to carry the body
away if you were only interested in
getting the diamonds back to your boy oh
pardon me I was only interested in
getting those diamonds for myself the
old double-cross
the guys have hired him to get the
diamond gets nothing that was the
general idea character cute isn't he he
of the body destroys it then tells the
diamond on us to go chase him sighs you
couldn't move precisely
yo Wells was not to be found at all I'll
tell them in a few years I'll sell those
diamonds at a slight loss from last year
trying to take what about the cops
well now believe what they believe for
five years I shall put mr. wells at the
bottom of the river
now they think he is anyhow yeah but
they'll be questions that tonight whom
will acquit follow me miss Gallagher and
you think you will be available for
questioning the stool is figured you
spell when you thought you have asthma
spud which are wrong
[Music]
it's the little man look at the bacon I
brought home where's clutch but what's
he got to deal with it and he hopefully
finished it herself didn't he get out of
cab
hey are you conscious there's no one in
the cab but that's dead no lady that's
no stiff that was clutch come on come on
donkey
and you mean all the time clutch was
doubling for the body of your well sure
I figured junk you try to knock us off
but you supposed to cover us with a gun
oh no wonder you were so brave back
there hey clutch clutch clutch wake up
hmm what know which way to go out get
him I'll get him with my heater take it
easy
I thought you were gonna funnel boom
utter I must have fell asleep just fine
I hope you had a nice nap
alright Jackie get in don't pull no
calisthenics bud
[Music]
well let's better be on the level that's
all I gotta say you see this guy's the
murderer or a reasonable facsimile hello
give me mine and who's this character
with a suit haircut
the name is clutch Tracy and my racket
happens to be impersonating
electrocution well if you don't believe
us now that are resent it well what do
you wait nan for I'm in a Cell you mean
you've got to give them a third degree
sure then we're gonna scalp him and hang
him up by his toes this I gotta see
hey Sarge give me a match with you
thanks you better keep a couple of these
in case you run shut hello Martin out of
your path wait for what the nerve of
them he's on another fault the story
ought to be good for you cheer up honey
hey Sarge you better get a hold of
lieutenant max early lieutenant Hurley
he's out on the cruise car the only way
I can reach him was by radio you better
get him I've got something he wants very
badly well this better be on the level
that's all written by Mike in the radio
second connected sergeant clothing 27
was hauling tire 27 come in lieutenant
Hurley Carly car 27 calling car 27
lieutenant met ferry come in that theory
what China lamebrain tomfoolery goes on
in that a lot of axes the speed will it
while you wingspan it in before what do
you think your temper temper
well if you don't tell me what you did
with Joe Wells off personally took you
up front like it like an artichoke
you've been riding around with him all
night ever since you left the freight
yard right Nora are you nuts
he's right behind you max in your trunk
in the either I put a man that is all
woman hey oh hello Martin now shut up I
didn't hurt you to wait for a little
vignette you might be able to use on
page one here it is Joe well supposedly
dead for five years was found murdered
tonight a tea oh wait a minute the
credit line on this story is by Pete
Willis and Sue Gallagher well she's
working for you now II I don't get the
yarn yeah okay very disappointed you
remember the time when they found the
guy in it well this is important
[Music]